nous sommes à clichy dans le nord de
paris comme chaque mois sarah julien est
garant son rendez vous avec delphine
pour la séance de travail des bip bip
traduisez pelvienne une parisse le
webzine culturel des belges à paris i
comment exprimer sa belgitude 132 thalys
j'ai trouvé une nouvelle chroniqueuse
elle est là dans le style est donc elle
est prête à aller faire tout les projets
projection au son de wallonie bruxelles
et tout ça et nous écrire des papiers
3000 amis sur facebook les bips cartonne
rédigé en français le site s'adresse à
toute la belgique
mouvement on englobe un petit peu l'idée
de d'image belge de culture belge est
alors signé il y en a qui se revendique
comme lg lyonnais qui se revendique
vraiment comme wallons comme flamands et
pour eux c'est pas pareil ça véhicule
pas les mêmes les mêmes idées les mêmes
valeurs la même folie pure en belgique
on est tous mixer moi j'ai une
grand-mère flamand de perdre anvers j'ai
grandi wallonie fin toute la journée
l'autre quoi il ya de tout
à l'autre bout de la capitale dans le
15e arrondissement
nous retrouvons frédéric la trentaine un
flamand installé à paris depuis deux ans
en belgique la victoire aux élections de
juin 2010 de la nva un parti séparatiste
a secoué les partisans d'une belgique
unie l'objectif de bart de wever son
leader est clair créer la république de
flandre frédéric lui n'est pas favorable
à la division ils accusent des médias de
faire un amalgame la preuve tapez
wallons et flamands sur google donc la
première chose qu'on voit c'est la
flotte demande de divorce après on voit
un pays divisé un politicien flamand
agressé
il faut chercher très loin en a marre
quelque chose positive sur sur la
belgique frédéric et le président de vip
vip où la mine guenoun parisse
l'association rassemble une centaine de
flamands dans la capitale leur petit
plaisir un dîner mensuel et là encore la
scission du pays est au centre des
débats
sonne est ce qu'on a en commun c'est con
on n'en connaît pas les parts
[Musique]
on figure pas on se lâche un peu le
français le néerlandais de langues un
seul pays la source du problème belge à
nos propres journaux écrits dans notre
langue on enlève notre propre chaîne de
télévision auquel et les fronts les
francophones allaient vraiment il faut
plutôt regarder ce qui se passe en
france est donc le nord leur chaîne
télévision ce qu'on partage rien au fait
qu'il ne parle pas le néerlandais et ils
ne peuvent pas suivre aussi les
actualités en flandre de cette façon ils
ne peuvent pas toujours fois la volonté
de racheter marielle parce que c'est
peut-être comme dans un mariage on
invite ensemble mais nous l'avons fait
chambre à part
retour chez les wallons ici on accuse
les politiciens d'alimenter une
polémique stérile c'est justement la
politique qui fait que maintenant les
gens sont là en train de revendiquer on
les bruxellois ont les flamands et les
wallons avant mais jamais j'entendais
dire autant voilà on revendiquait pas
plus que ça le perso ça me ferait super
mal de plus mais je crois ça serait
enfin c'est comme ben voilà devenir en
sortent d'une sorte d'apatrides suite
est né dans un pays il existe plus
pourtant même chez les flamands de paris
l'idée de la division du pays divisant
on se sont d'abord belges et après ainsi
une vache en dix ans alors qu'on a mangé
examen mais
dans un pays qui s'appelle on était
amené son abomination
avant on était très très malmenées parce
que bon il y avait que la langue
française qui comptait avant et c'est
vrai qu'il ya peut-être une revanche
culturel parce que pendant 100 ans entre
1930 et
[Musique]
1940 c'est toujours la communauté
linguistique francophone qui a dominé le
pays mais c'est clair que les 150
dernières années ça a complètement
changé chez les francophones on ne veut
pas entendre parler d'une wallonie
orpheline de la flandre ont l'intention
la wallonie va moins bien pour le moment
mais la flandre oublie qu'à un moment
c'était elle qu'elle est moins bien
voilà ça ç'a toujours été des vases
communicants moi je vois ça un peu de
l'extérieur comme un vieux couple qui
s'engueulent depuis des années mais qui
peut pas vivre vraiment l'un sans
l'autre et puis tu dis ben hassine
énième menace de divorce qui va encore
pas aboutir quoi parce qu'on sait qu'ils
peuvent perdre ans c'est pareil pour que
ceux qui gagnent pas les enfants
aujourd'hui un pont est tendue entre les
deux communautés frédéric le flamand et
sarah et julien les wallons se sont
donné rendez vous place pigalle devant
un petit théâtre alors vous savez ce
qu'on va voir ce soit vous pouvez relire
audard par les identités de carte
d'identité
ou la guerre soissons déclaration de
guerre ou pas non c'est gentil
rona est un humoriste bruxellois mais
c'est à paris qu'il a choisi de monter
sur scène ce soir il joue son spectacle
carte d'identité pour lui wallons
flamands une distinction vaseuses c'est
quoi être belge c'est ça le truc c'est
ça c'est justement cherche à répondre à
cette question c'est pour ça qu'elle ait
conflit
la force de roda c'est de brocarder tout
le monde sans distinction
moi je sais pas pourquoi les français
vous dit toujours que les belges sont
sympas
vous avez jamais été en belgique
est ce qu'on va faire en belgique pour
s'intégrer à prendre le flamand
[Musique]
comment je vous mets au défi de draguer
en flamand je t'aime
et caen vannes yahoo
vous imaginez on vous dit ça dans le
noir
ce soir les susceptibilités
communautaires sont restées au placard
alors inimaginable de ne pas terminer la
soirée autour d'une bière non il faut
pas dramatiser
c'est un peu l'histoire c'est l'histoire
qui se répète un peu l'éternel combat
entre les coques et le lion
après une bonne douche roda via
rejoindre ses nouveaux fans on voit bien
avant mon félicitations
après juste que les gens sachent que les
belges ne parle pas comme ça
c'est pas un accent belge
comme quoi l'humour belge n'est pas une
légende il a au moins le mérite de
réconcilier les wallons et les flamands
de paris